what's up wisecrack
jared again if there's one thing people
know about quentin tarantino outside his
proclivity for
foul language and violence it's his
profound love for cinema
this obsession with film is littered
throughout his work
with entire movies that function as
homages to spaghetti westerns
classic kung fu and blaxploitation and
of course his newest film is set in
1960s hollywood
now while these films may implicitly
celebrate the medium that's so dear to
his heart
it's in his nazi-killing classic in
glorious bastards that we see his most
significant statement
on the power of film a statement that
today
may no longer ring true so let's figure
out why in this wisecrack edition on
inglorious bastards
and of course spoilers ahead alright
guys
first a quick recap in glorious bastard
starts with the
jew hunter hans landa pursuing his
victims in the french countryside he's
able to suss out the dreyfus family but
one young woman shoshanna narrowly
escapes
meanwhile a select group of american
jews known as the bastards
led by lieutenant aldo rayne are waging
a guerrilla war in nazi territory and
collecting as many nazi scalps as
possible
each and every man under my command owes
me 100
nazi scallops the bastard set off to
infiltrate the premiere of joseph
goebbel's newest piece of propaganda
nation's pride a screening which will be
attended by the entire nazi high command
also this cinema happens to be run by
none other than shoshanna who plans to
burn the place down on premiere night
both plans more or less work out and the
leaders of the third reich are butchered
in a blaze of flames and a hail of
bullets
it rules while all this is happening
landa captures aldo and negotiates his
defection but
as soon as landa crosses into allied
territory reign
kills his escort and leaves landa a
little something to remember him by
i think this just might be my
masterpiece even in that summary the
role of film is pretty clear
the climactic events of the story are
centered around a film screening
but even before the screening the
bastards meet a german actress bridget
von hammersmark
people throughout the movie reference
specific german films like the white
hell of pitzpaloo and filmmakers like gw
pabst
as scholar susan suleiman notes even the
title is an intentional misspelling of
enzo castellari's 1978 film
the inglorious bastards tarantino quote
changed the spelling to acknowledge both
his debt and his difference to the film
but beyond including
references to film which is not exactly
novel for tarantino
inglorious bastards is meta-cinematic in
other words
it's a film about film the whole plot
ends up being framed
not just around the nation's pride
premiere but the broader german culture
of film
goebbels considers the films he's making
to be the beginning of a new era
in german cinema an alternative to what
he considers the jewish german
intellectual cinema of the twenties
and the jewish-controlled dogma of
hollywood it's no mistake that
goebbels the propaganda minister is
prominent throughout
historically the nazi party had several
mediums for propaganda at their disposal
but they heavily exploited the power of
cinema even today propaganda films like
reefenstall's triumph of the will
are appreciated for their technical
prowess but condemned for their
disturbing ability to deify hitler
the nazi propaganda machine created a
lot of modern filmmaking
but also showed the danger of its powers
in the wrong hands
with inglorious bastards tarantino
suggests that just as cinema built the
nazis up
so too can it tear them down in making a
film that relishes in the highly
stylized murder of the nazi regime
tarantino wields the same power once
wielded by goebbels
except this time with the opposite
message bastards goes to great lengths
to establish that in its universe the
camera
is more powerful than the sword their
contact in germany is a british agent
chosen for his cinema expertise
and i've had two books published
impressive
and don't be modest left ten what are
the titles the first book was called
art of the eyes of heart and the mind
study of german cinema in the 20s
and the second one was called 24 frame
da vinci
it's a subtextual film criticism study
of the work of german director g
w pabst turns out he's not a great spy
as he botches the mission but
that's the point season
it's more important that he understands
cinema than
spycraft because that's where the real
battle is being fought
this is a running theme in the movie the
germans love to use cinema as a tool of
propaganda
and that adoration of the medium leaves
them vulnerable to penetration
film culture is like the exhaust port on
the nazi death star
during the screening marcel shoshanna's
lover and projectionist
lights a pile of 35 millimeter film on
fire
and starts a conflagration that consumes
the cinema
the nazi high command is destroyed in a
theater by a fire
started by film it's almost two on the
nose
one could interpret this to say it's
cinema that killed the nazis
we're gonna be doing one thing and one
thing only
killing nazis we can really see the
cinema as war comparison when shoshanna
kills zuller in the projection room
zuller in nation's pride snipes his
enemies from above in a bell tower
but in the cinema it's inverted this
time he's still
up high in the projection booth
separated from the battle below
but he's the victim his heroism on the
field of battle
is undermined and taken away in the
context of the theater
in this version of world war ii it's not
tanks snipers or bombers that end the
war
instead it's a cinema owner some jewish
gorilla soldiers
and a film that destroys the nazi
machine it's no coincidence that a
director with a profound love of cinema
ends his movie about cinema with this
iconic quote
[ __ ] i think this just might be
nice to be this isn't just rain talking
about his ability to carve up nazis
but tarantino using the lieutenant as a
mouthpiece to say that this movie
is his own masterpiece his own testament
to the power of cinema
tarantino even said in an interview all
that happens in inglorious bastards is
because of the cinema
and it's not a metaphor the 35
millimeter cinema
killed the third reich i'm not ashamed
to say that this idea was one of the
best moments of my life as an author
now obviously bastards is an alternate
history hitler didn't really get gunned
down in a theater but
that speaks to the broader point cinema
didn't storm normandy but it won the war
in people's minds
and kept it one during and after the war
cinema served to cement
anti-nazism as the norm for american
culture
a culture which was widely exported
around the globe
nazis have remained a symbol of evil in
many movies ranging from
sly stallone soccer movies to indiana
jones adventures in the desert
to captain america punching hitler in
the face tarantino suggests that 35
millimeter film
and the medium of cinema in general is
the cultural safeguard
that killed the echoes of nazism and
kept them
dead but was he right over the past few
years we've seen a rise in xenophobic
neo-fascist political groups
the golden dawn in greece the
alternative for germany party
and white nationalists in the usa the
degree to which these groups can be
likened to hitler's nazis
varies but the shared dna is pretty easy
to spot
there's also been a rise in anti-semitic
and racist violence
and nazi-esque content on the internet
with all of this happening and growing
every day
it's safe to say that maybe tarantino's
theory that 35 millimeter cinema killed
nazism for good
doesn't hold up so what happened
why isn't cinema enough anymore well to
answer that let's first discuss why
cinema ever worked in the first place
it's clear from the film that tarantino
is primarily concerned with the power of
movies writ large and the act
of going to the theater it's a communal
activity shared with many people
all of whom are experiencing the same
thing you are this especially matters
because it turns watching movies into a
ritual
ritual doesn't mean goat sacrificing or
pentagrams necessarily it simply means a
set of activities that distinguish one
moment from the mundane time surrounding
it
paying for a ticket finding your seat
and watching the movie
all amount to an experience of ritual
that makes the movie itself more
resonant
because as psychologists have argued
ritualizing activities lends them a
greater
error of importance for tarantino this
is most true in the experience of
film in particular he shoots all of his
movies on film
argued against having his movies
digitally projected and only shows
film at the theater he owns in los
angeles the added ritual elements of
film
the sound of the projector the changing
of the reels the need for a
projectionist
all serve to supercharge the ritual
elements of the theater
that power enables the stories we tell
on film to have a lasting
impact among communities strong enough
the film asserts
to keep the third reich dead
unfortunately that's no longer how it
goes
you can stay abreast of every major
movie release without ever leaving your
bed
there's no built-in ritual to engaging
with movies on your laptop
this not only means movies no longer
resonate like they used to but that
people have the ability to curate their
own cultural experience
in a way that is hyper tailored to their
interests with the disillusion of
cinema's poignancy
comes the loss of its powers the source
of all this is pretty clear
it's the internet dummy but to
understand exactly how it happened
we'll have to turn to a scholar who'd
been speculating about the internet
before it was even a twinkly network of
tubes in al gore's eye
media theorist marshall mcluhan in his
final work the global village he
referred to the future information
superhighway as
global media networking one offshoot of
this new development as he predicted it
was the death of monoculture or in other
words
everyone doing their own thing this
setup of everyone choosing culture a la
carte to fit their interests
is a symptom of what mcluhan called
robotism
robotism or right hemisphere thinking is
a capacity to be a conscious presence
in many places at once mcluhan saw
technology as pushing humanity toward a
confrontation with two different ways of
thought
left hemisphere thinking which is
associated with hierarchical reasoning
and visual space
and right hemisphere thinking which is
associated with more primitive
intuitions
and acoustic space for mcluhan the
western world has been dominated by left
hemisphere thinking
but technology is pushing us toward
right hemisphere thinking
or robotism the left hemisphere assumes
shared culture and rules
one example of this is the shared ideal
that nazis are bad and maybe should get
scalped
on the other hand there's the right
brain thinking that rejects these shared
ideas and has everyone coming up with
their own systems of belief and behavior
now the actual neuroscience of this is
spotty at best as
recently scientists have poked holes in
the idea of left and right brain
thinking
but his identification of the hidden
effects of technology
remains prescient we're losing shared
culture
every day sure there's a few vestiges of
monoculture like game of thrones and the
avengers
but mostly people are free to consume
their own highly personalized suggestion
algorithm
this arrangement is a double-edged sword
on the one hand the splintering of
society leaves a space for all kinds of
cool things
like a youtube channel that analyzes
philosophy and culture
at the same time it also leaves room for
behavior that we socially agreed is bad
to blossom like nazism mcluhan explains
this as a result of the loss of a ruling
center
robotism is also decentralizing he
writes culture becomes organized like an
electric circuit
each point in the net as central as the
next electronic man loses
touch with the concept of a ruling
center as well as the social restraints
based on interconnection hierarchies
constantly dissolve
and reform by ruling center mcluhan
means the set of beliefs we all
share to make sure society works we all
agree that it's good to be nice and bad
to
i don't know kill jews for their
ancestry but that system only holds
because we all think it makes sense
as that shared agreement becomes weaker
the nastiness it holds back
can come to the fore this is what
mcluhan means when he compares society
to an electrical circuit
in a circuit each point contributes to
the whole rather than there being a
central source
you can reorganize the circuit at any
point the same is true for our culture
now
there's no fixed ethical center so you
might get your ethics from
facebook twitter something awful 4chan
snapchat youtube
or any other digital hell hole that
source can be different for anyone
and as such prevents us all from
agreeing to a set of rules and behaviors
that brings us back to tarantino's ideas
about cinema at the end of the day the
reason 35 millimeter film
killed the nazis is by virtue of an
appeal to that ruling center
cinema was a defining force of culture
and brought with it
narratives and ideals now this isn't
always good i.e
reef and stahl and the nazis but for the
most part movies serve to cement the
ideas that define
society where once cinema was able to
relay these
critical social messages now that we're
all suffering from a severe case of
robotism
not so much so with this cultural
acceleration well underway and
all of us seeing and feeling the effects
of robotism what does that mean for our
good buddy quinton
after all this is the man who shoots all
of his movies on film and even resisted
letting them be digitally screened
he's a ferocious defender of the theater
experience
and the history of film yet his thesis
on the power of cinema
seems no longer relevant so what's an
auteur to do
well step one is adapt and against all
odds we can see
tarantino doing exactly that he just
released his latest film the hateful
eight as a four-part
mini-series on netflix just a few years
ago this would have been
unthinkable for him yet here we are
even tarantino is seeing the future and
making choices to keep his voice a part
of the culture
going forward but he's not all the way
done with the past either
his next and allegedly second to last
film is set in 1969
a time when cinema was inarguably a
central cultural ritual of america
it raises the question of tarantino's
love of the past and disdain for the
future will play a part in that story
will it just be nostalgia for a time
tarantino better understood
is it just an inroad to an unlimited
buffet of film references
or will he acknowledge that maybe film
isn't as powerful as he thought it would
be and show us a different perspective
on cinema
one that accounts for the changes he
didn't see coming either way we can't
wait to see how tarantino's latest work
fits into our ever
[Music]
[Applause]
fracturing
[Music]